[Applaudissements]
il va voom il va vous chantez des
génériques télé à vous de trouver de
quoi il s'agit dès que vous avez la
bonne réponse vous lever la main bien
sûr charlotte vous jouez avec nous tu es
prêt dès le générique de soda avec kev
adams à l'erreur ce soir c'est parce
qu'au moins facile enfin normalement
allez vous jouer également chez la la
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va de james sheppard par
celui-là il est un peu plus compliqué
allez on y va
le premier était facile à trouver tout
de suite elle est mal et se sent très
bon elle a l'oreille
ouais c'est sûr alors on l'a pas leurs
ouailles c'est parti mon vélo
[Musique]
là
oh la la
non
là
aulas
la lola
quelle foi quand même énorme oui et oui
on l'a vu ce week-end les gars mais l on
n'est pas loin de france amène à quoi ça
peut être un jeu gagner des minutes et
tu chantes chantes chantes ce refrain
qui te plaît mais tu danses dans ce sens
c'est ta façon d'aimer vers koné ou pas
oui j'en fais les chroniqueurs dont les
chroniqueurs de touche pas à mon poste
ont tous un talent encaisser leurs
chèques balancer sur leurs collègues et
être de batman mais s'ils ont bien un
talent mais s'il ya bien un talent
qu'ils n'ont pas fait celui de chanter
pour le ba ba du poste du pire chanteur
de l'année
les nommés sont à
dans la catégorie pire chanteur gilles
verdez matthieu delormeau jean michel mr
et le gagnant est
6il jour des saints
[Applaudissements]